welcome back to new rockstars one
division episode eight spoiler warning
uh gave us some nice juicy questions
uh including what is white vision uh
what's gonna happen in this finale
episode are the kids
all right are they gonna be okay uh well
i'm eric boss i'm here with jessica
clements on
stereo taking some stereo questions here
this is a bonus q a that we're doing
with our listeners over there
we are recording this live the morning
after the episode and you can actually
join us future weeks for
the finale episode and for other after
shows that we might do in the future
by downloading stereo for free at
stereo.com new rockstars
let us begin by taking our first
question
do you think that wanda's kids are
actually alive
what a good question so what have we
learned about the kids in this episode
it seemed like they
are for sure manifested magic but
that they are being uh used by agatha in
that final moment to
try to manipulate wanda the way
everything is being manipulated we heard
their voices echoing through the
basement
but we didn't know exactly where they
were in that basement which is
especially odd because that basement is
supposed to be
outside of the hex right is it so
i thought it was just is it outside of
the hex i thought it was still inside
the hex but she
put the since she had the symbols the
magic on it
that she couldn't use her magic within
it only only the person that created
that hex
could use the magic in that in the
basement which was agatha
um yeah i do think the children are so i
thought it was in there still and i also
think
because she knows because obviously
wanda's having a hard time
understanding the fact that her children
are not real that she created this
and and agatha does know that i think
agatha was taking control of the
children and
just manipulating their voices literally
like annihilation
uh where it's like the animal is just
like reciting the last words of the
people it killed
um i think it's just kind of like doing
that where it's just throwing its voices
because she's a witch like she obviously
is making that stuff apparent
but i don't think the kids are real i
don't think the kids are real maybe
their souls will go
somewhere but like i don't even i don't
think
they're not real yeah i don't think
they're real but i think their souls
could come back in the mcu because we
know they're setting up the young
avengers right we yeah
uh uh hawkeye kate bishop is coming in
in the hawkeye series
cassie lange is coming up in ant-man in
the wasp quantomania
uh and wicken and speed uh billy and
tommy if they wanted these kids just to
be random kids that just faded away they
wouldn't call them billy and tommy
i think that is a sign that these kids
are going to come back in some form
reincarnated in some form
now billy and tommy like many thing in
the scarlet witch and vision series
the story is never truly coherent or
linear with how these people get brought
into
the world and with billy and tommy are
so freaking weird like
they start out as pieces of mephisto's
soul like tricks but then like
mephisto uh is like attacked so he can't
ever like fully stay in his full form
until later and then
uh the kids get brought back into the
universe as
mutants who at first we don't really
know that they are the same kids
uh as who were scarlet which is kids but
then they are later
uh back defined as like oh those are the
same kids
and they're mutants and that's why
wiccans of sorcery is like wanda sorcery
and uh yes so i i don't think it's gonna
be the same actors i think these kids
are a bit young
um but i think they're gonna cast some
bigger name actors to play them in a
future young avengers team up in on
disney plus
or mcu yeah i can't wait to see it
can't wait to see yeah now the question
is it's just like how
uh what does real mean in the purposes
of the hex
um because we know that uh vision in the
hex was
just wanda's magic bringing him back she
did not steal
vision's corpse uh and we know that it
looks like pietro
is something similar that agatha did
that she just used magic
to incarnate him you know and she
puppets him around
so these kids look like they're sort of
the same thing um so are they going to
be pieces of mephisto's soul i think so
i think unleash hell demon's bond means
that like next week it's going to be
implied that they're
pieces of a demonstration yeah you
really hung up on that
i have a duty to be hung up on it
it just opens so many more doors which
isn't a problem but it opens so many
more
questions if their souls go into other
things it's like
so so vision does have a soul
and she created it well she's god yeah
yeah
so but i think vision so many things but
what vision soul was
was already something a bit artificial
to begin with it was the mind stones
ai that was like you know bleeding
through the rest of his vibranium body
and that had a humanistic element to it
because the mind stone has some sort of
cosmic intelligence to it
and that mixed with all the other
factors um
sorcery in a way to to make vision have
a quote-unquote soul so i think wand is
capable
through her mindstone-derived powers at
this point it's not wein's
mindstone derived it's want mind stone
powered powers
amplified powers uh was able to
incarnate
this version of vision soul but it seems
to be tied to her own memories right
he's he's not fully there with all of
vision's memories it's not real
yeah yeah so i think she can like bring
up that soul but i think these boys
as pieces of mephisto's soul i don't
think they're true souls in the way that
like
herb has a soul or you know mrs hart has
a soul these other westview
people have a soul um so we're back to
now acknowledging mafesto
is in this he has to be in this world
which you are already on
he doesn't have to i just think that
you're already on board
yeah well i do think the kids are going
somewhere so they have to be attached
tangentially or whatever
to me or someone yeah okay
let's take another question from our
favorite animals
did wanda create vibranium
since hayward was still tracking
decaying vibranium how was he tracking
that
i asked this on twitter i asked this on
twitter because i was like it's so
confusing
that she can create vibranium and how
that isn't a problem
because they were tracking decaying
vibranium unless that was a lie
unless cataracts was something else but
they were
tracking vision in there
somehow and so if they were tracking it
by vibranium that means that this woman
straight up
created some material that is mirroring
vibranium
or is vibranium which is possible i
guess because she is ultimately the
strongest person but that itself is a
problem
that's very dangerous if she's creating
vibranium
well i think what we learned is that
wanda's uh
ability to rewrite reality this way and
i think this is why agatha's so blown
away by her
she is a nexus being she can kind of
create anything from her mind
and i think in this case yeah within
this hex uh
vision is made of vibranium now as we
see
as he tries to step away from the hex he
starts to fall apart and his pieces get
sucked back into the hex
so i don't think in this case he can
fully last and survive
because he doesn't have a corporeal form
unlike you know um
monica's fish pants based off of a
kevlar best
vest that came from the outside and then
it can go back out and still live on in
some kind of kevlar form that's been
rewritten vision can't
but yeah he for the purposes within that
hex he still has
a vibranium form she was able to create
that uh
and that means she can create anything
she can create a whole like a cubic
brick of vibranium she can create gold
diamonds as much as she wants to do
uh any kind of irradiating uh you know
just a huge supply of plutonium if she
wanted to
and that's where i think i keep getting
tripped up on because i'm like that is
utter power that is straight insanity
but with me thinking that i'm also not
taking into a fact like how doctor
strange is also very powerful but he
also uses his magic for good and
controls it and doesn't use it to just
bring
steal money from a bank so i think
ultimately i'm like
wanda can do anything but wanda in the
comic books also could do everything but
she didn't like do
everything she wasn't like you know what
i'm gonna play god and just destroy it
while she did
but she well she kind of did but she oh
she didn't do that every day she wasn't
like i'm just gonna bring this plane
down from the sky because i'm bored
right if she was a villain she would be
unstoppable but that's i think
because she's a good person she's not
gonna be doing that stuff
so she i think she might be a villain
it's going to be insane this woman can
create vibranium
if she can create vibranium but also to
be fair
i guess she's creating vibranium in her
world in her hex
can she make vibranium outside of the
hex and so
well it has to be in the in a reality
that she creates and i think that's why
the support
as we see the multiverse getting created
she is powerful
to create new realities that project
from her mind but those realities are
real to the people who live
in them and i think she needs to be that
powerful in order to be
such a threat and multiverse of madness
and like if she couldn't create
vibranium she wouldn't be as interesting
of a nexus being she has to be able to
do that but and
even though it is god level power i
think the more the greater the power the
greater the cost
i mean that's the classic uncle ben
paraphrase right uh great bower comes
great responsibility
i think the the more god level she goes
the greater grief and brokenness she's
going to feel
so i just need true which is a good
justification they did a really good job
with this
uh show especially of just like the
writing because my whole thing about any
any
form of entertainment i need a good damn
justification
i need it to be understand and this one
has some strong good
like more than one so i'm like good on
you guys you guys did a really good job
but yeah i i get they yeah okay so
that's definitely where it's gonna be
showing up and like spider-man is like
yeah she's the ultimate threat
spider-man can't go against her on his
own
she could create it's gonna be great
there's a whole world
that literally runs off this crap and
this crap
this stuff and she's straight up making
it from air
this is a weapon that people die over
and she's just like you know what i'm
just gonna make it
i'm gonna make it out of my man let's
take another question because we have a
whole bunch we're gonna try to get
through as many as we can
you think that the vision
that they allowed wanda to see
was a decoy because at the end of
infinity wars he was gray
but when she went to see him he was back
to being red or purple
oh i like it i don't think it was a
decoy but you are
thinking on the right lines because i
think what we saw
in that autopsy that dismantling was
kind of a show
it was like that wouldn't be how sword
agents really
worked on visions body hayward set that
up in order to manipulate wanda
into trying to be like no no let me take
him let me try to bring him back to life
and that's what hayward wanted
so i but i don't think it was a decoy i
think what you're seeing is just like
the infinity war artist
it wasn't like gray vision it was just
desaturated vision yeah
and i think that's what wanda vision is
showing us it's just desaturated
uh and that means corpse vision i don't
think it's like two different visions
one's
full gray and one is like gray but also
a bit of
red hue in there i agree
but that would be a very fun rogue
theory yeah
and who knows we might be wrong that
might be he might have it might be
a decoy vision corpse make this one real
wiry inside yeah
also our theory that she was just
slinging a corpse around in there is
completely false now
and i'm actually happy for that because
they probably were like disney was like
you guys are
mad men if you think we just put up the
corpse
flying around in this just ragdolling a
corpse just bleeding everywhere
literally
we literally believed it we were like
yeah they straight up dug up
his body and just start flying it around
all right let's take another question
where do you think
monica and pietro are right now
because this time has passed and they
didn't show a single bit of them
i don't think that much time has passed
that's my theory i think everything we
saw in this episode occurred in
uh maybe 60 seconds there's like a blink
of an eye it was a mental conversation
that was happening
um yeah i don't i don't get it
i don't think it was i think it was
maybe a little bit longer even if it was
a blink of the eye
i think it was the same while that was
happening mirroring the same time was
pietro monica and then vision finding
him
um finding them um because and i think
that's what we're going to get next
episode and that's why we're going to
jump into wanda still in her because
in a lot of the trailers she's wearing
that track suit
she's wearing that so i think that's
like we're just going to jump right back
into it
we're going to jump right back into it
maybe it's going to be quick yeah but
i think yeah we're definitely jumping
back into it i think episode 9 is going
to open with like
monica's next you might see a bit of a
battle between monica and pietro
i don't think we're going to see a team
up just because i it now seems like
pietro is really just a
you know an extension of agatha and then
um
vision's going to help monica uh
overcome
pietro uh and it's you know they're
gonna team up as a result of that battle
so i think it's gonna go against pietro
and vision's gonna go against vision
and then yeah that's the brawl it's
gonna be a classic uh monday night raw
rubble it's gonna be paper baby
pay-per-view
they're gonna make you pay for the last
episode and disney knows i would
that's the trick that's the damn catch
if disney was like forty dollars for the
last episode i'd be like
i'm pulling out my wallet when
white vision comes in you're gonna hear
the glass breaking sound effect and the
siren and he's just gonna do stone cold
and then chug a beer and he's like
and that's the bottom line because white
vision said so i love that wanda
literally watched every old-timey
hollywood show and then started watching
wwe
she started watching wwe in 2001 and was
like ooh
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's take another question do you think
that it's possible that the human torch
shows up in the finale like the west
coast avengers around
yeah well i was thinking about that too
i yeah they that's another thing that's
from the comics yeah
human torch there's like a suspicion
because originally vision's body was
made from the original golden age human
torch
i think there's like a link between not
johnny storm
like the the old human torch so human
torch comes back in this west coast
avengers story line if you look at these
comics it's like why is johnny storm
there
um because he's part of it and he uh so
a lot of people think like oh
is vision connected to johnny storm to
the human torch that was part of the
misdirect with bringing him back
i don't think human torch is going to
show up in this uh it would also
be way too big yeah yeah i think it'd be
too it would be too many it would be too
many hands on the pot too many levels
too much confusion but i mean i love the
eye and that's the earth
a lot of people make towards uh mephisto
like it'd be too confusing i'm like no
i think this table is set for some kind
of demonic entity whether it's
a nightmare or someone but like if you
were to bring in a member of the
fantastic four
it's they're so big in the world of
marvel that like
that's gonna overshadow all the
witchcraft all the uh
the depression all the human story that
they're telling i don't
think we're gonna get we may be in a
post-credits scene or something like
that but then
that's what i think we're gonna get
that's what we'll get something
yeah it's like a human torch in that
case i don't think so no
i think it's gonna be mephisto i think
the and then that's gonna be like oh
here's but you're and then you get
you're sad you're crying and then at the
end of the credits you're like yes
yes i was right
i'll just lay down and rest finally i'll
sleep
for some years and then curl up into a
ball
and then come out as a butterfly i'm
gonna jeepers creepers it i'm gonna come
back every 23rd spring
or whatever scrapers
but yeah i don't think it's gonna be
human torch unfortunately eric
witches can be good they can
you heard her you
just to be the confusion on my face of
when you were like
it's the future she can see i was like
raven from teen titans i was like
what and then i was like you're an idiot
i'm not the idiot
yes raven uh raven's good there's lots
of good witches out there
and i'm just saying this coven in
particular did not look like a good
group
and they did not look like a group that
wanted to be good i think she meant good
like
i can be one of you i can be not as dark
as you accuse me of being
um i just thought it was interesting
that they they have their own definition
of good
which is just killing local kids i'll
just eat [ __ ] kids
you know hey sometimes you got to do
what you got to do before we continue
thank you to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang energy has zero
calories zero carbs zero
sugars and zero artificial flavors each
16-ounce can
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
super creatine coq10 and bcaas i am
sipping on
rainbow unicorn not like those
thundercloud unicorns the unicorns that
make you feel happy when you sip them
it's just sweet and light like you're on
the back of a unicorn
leaping over a more depressed unicorn i
honestly rely on bangs when i'm shooting
those early morning after shows
and i don't want my eyes to look like
i'm half asleep when i'm trying to break
down these easter eggs i need my mind to
be alert
check out bang on instagram you can get
10 off your order at bang energy.com
when you use the code new rockstars 10.
rainbow there you can buy a variety pack
of bang energy or grab a 12 pack of
citrus twist bankster berry the new
delish
strawberry kiss use my code new
rockstars 10 and receive
10 off your bang energy order that's
code new rockstars 10 for
10 off all right so when agatha said she
had like the basic protection spell
runes on her wall
did you see that there was one that was
an m because i know eric
like this could really just feed into
the mephisto train like i'm on that
train too
damn you guys are feeding his mephisto
knees y'all just giving it to him now
you guys just want him to be
you guys are cheering him on to be wrong
uh it did look kind of like an m one
looked like a crop circle a little bit i
think they were
trying to make it look like some kind of
uh old
language some old runes um to me
it didn't look so much like an m just
like oh it has like three downward kind
of things
swooshes swopes but uh if if mephisto
isn't this i don't think we'll be able
to go back to that room and be like aha
that's that's what it was that was the
clue that told us that it was mephisto
i think he's gonna come out of the dark
hold if he is and this or he's gonna
that rabbit's gonna turn into a famous
actor
that paul bettany has always wanted to
work with who's not it's called that
name
it's he's just false well benny is
literally playing this is the
eddie murphy he's playing every
character he's been doing a great
elizabeth olsen
impression so talented
uh let's take another question do you
think that
white vision will share
any of the memories of original
vision oh yeah it goes back to what we
talked about a little bit
where i would this is where i was like
it's just gonna be like gamora all over
again where they're gonna have to teach
her
what she was before they got the new
gamora
that's why i don't think he'll have the
vision memories
that's why just because it's so close to
that storyline i think they wouldn't do
that
see i don't think white vision's going
to say anything i think he's going to be
just a creepy mute
vision fights with uh kind of like
uh bizarro superman and superman 3 the
richard pryor one the best one
it's crazy and goofy and silly and i
love it i read
i was reading online on twitter where
everyone was like what if he has
ultron's voice and i was like
ultron had the hottest voice in the
world so i am completely down with that
but they're gonna drop someone they're
gonna bring james peter back in the hot
adr booth
i don't know um yeah i i don't think
he's gonna talk at all and if he does
talk and have paul benny's voice i'll be
a little
irritated i'll be like oh come on you
guys rebooted him like
yeah he literally rebooted him i think
he will
i think we will see a version of vision
in the future that has vision's full
memories i think
their conscious the the body of white
vision and then the consciousness the
walking consciousness that is this
vision
will get merged and then from that we'll
get a moment where
he remembers everything and it may just
be like a fleeting moment in the finale
where
wanda and vision connect finally before
they go their separate ways
um but yeah i don't think paul bettany's
done after
one division i think he's got some
future ahead of him
even if it's just a simple um jarvis e
ai that's called vision training future
avengers like uh
charlie and charlie's angels oh yeah
won't he be helping the x-men eventually
oh sorry yeah
in the comics he definitely was as the
white avenger
for a minute yeah he does for a bit
and um vision's voice kind of is
the impetus to the young avengers
forming you know you have nathaniel
richards who's kind of like iron
lad who's like a descendant of reed
richards in the distant future
and then his future is to become kang
the conqueror but they're kind of
separate people in a way
and then so he's trying not to become
that yeah young nathaniel richards
ends up uh getting some kind of like
stark tech or
no it's like read richard's tech and
then he goes back to the present day and
finds visions
uh vision and like takes his yeah and he
becomes basically
vision it's kind of a mix of mission
and iron man tech because he's like
vision's like here's how we have to
restart
the avengers initiative so that voice
ends up kind of guiding him to become
iron lad
and then find patriot and hulk lane and
all the others y'all
it's comic books it overlaps it's in the
most confusing way
but it just is endless it is so endless
yeah uh let's take another question
what's your
theory on when wanda created
or basically took over west view how
everything was read
with the exception of when she was
bringing vision back
it was yellow similar to the mine stone
yeah i think you you said it right it's
it's not
uh it's a truth not
an illusion in that case the fact that
vision comes back with this kind of
golden glow i think
that color is a direct reference to the
mind stone and that's the link between
them and that's why
she kind of has this love uh yeah
i think that's why he's different it was
a way to communicate to the audience be
like the way she's building him
is kind of a life force it's not um
a false negative thing i agree
concur i can i don't have any theory
beyond your question i think you said it
yeah you said it man good job my dude
do you think that westview was actually
the perfect
place for wanda to do the hex
unintentionally just because it looked
like that town
was deserted and people were in grief
like mrs hart looks
sad yeah and then i don't know that's
what do you think i tried to make it
they tried to make it like she
assimilated it for a good reason
like the episode of rick and morty how
it was like she went to the planet
and literally like everything was upside
down until i showed you
our nipples before you don't understand
west view was crazy
yeah what are your nipples where are
normal levels
um but yeah marvel world i love it i
love seeing people try to put pieces
back together again they did the same
thing that like scott lang walking
through san francisco
there were no leaf blowers during the
blip people just let things over grow
all the gardeners got blipped oh you
know what are we gonna do without the
gardeners
yeah i think that was perfect all these
people were sad kind of aimless and i
think by the time this
but now they're in pain
no i think it was good that they got it
to escape
is like it was an improvement on what
they had before and they're like you
know what
even though she's painted as a villain
right now she gave me something
that helped alleviate my grief for a
period of time
um then again you could say abby lash
was freaked out he's like i want to call
my family
yeah my dad's dead now thanks
i don't know i i thought more so what
you were saying was like they're looking
back at it like
oh i'm thankful for what i have now
because what i had before
was painful and i hated it um i'm also
kind of
like irritated that like we were like oh
why
westview why did she come to west view
and the reason she came to west view is
because that was the plot of land that
they were gonna buy
i thought there was like a west view was
very specific like it's weird that
there's also a missing person there and
they were also gonna build a house there
and it's just by coincidence i was like
come on
well to me i know i like that jessica i
like that it was a simple emotional
reason
and that's you know when you're trying
to reveal stuff usually it's much better
if it's like simpler it's grounded it's
something that
makes you cry a little bit and i think
that was awesome i
i like that i prefer that honestly to it
oh there happens to be
a uh a magnetic hellhole nexus point
that just happens to be under this new
jersey town
i think that would be too wild i think
it's now i don't know why
not this small little new jersey town
would be the best place to retire
my friend also he's you can't change
well i guess he has no state income tax
um i'm just saying washington state has
so much land that you could use and
don't have to worry about the sad
neighbors that you have
um and it is it's basically my the sad
neighbors
stop it and i come from uh polar
opposite ends of the continental united
states
and that is also why yeah come to the
pacific
artist shade we have whales
they have alligators we have whales
both can kill you but ours are like they
don't know better i don't
know better tilikum is from washington
um
haven't you haven't you seen blackfish
the documentary where
it's an evil whale it's from washington
oh he's not evil he's misunderstood and
trained he is misunderstood i'm sorry
you guys
that are whale fans he was hella
misunderstood but he is also from
washington state
uh-huh that's our claim to fame no tilly
comes first
till he comes first and then everybody
and then matt greening
um but going back i did like that
yes oh don't you even start with jimi
hendrix again i will
jump through this screen and choke you
out so that was very violent it's really
it's really early to have two red bulls
i will jump through this screen and
punch a hole in your
heart so i i really like that scene in
one division where
um agatha that's then this is why i
think i l i wanted more of a reason
because i like the agatha was like
you did all this magic and i sensed it
that's why i came here
she was like i felt that crap from
light years away and was like i'm
showing up to what this is
that's why i was like i like there being
a reasoning because it was like
actually just showed up randomly it's
like no your power
was so big you didn't even think that it
would cause people to come look for you
that people wouldn't come and be like
what's going on here like other
magicians
like the idea of like um which spidey
sense that they can sense yeah
my knee hurts a storm's coming or
there's a witch in new jersey so
i like i love that i love that idea of
just like
girl you thought rupturing this like
little town was gonna not call awareness
to other villains
like you think villains weren't gonna
show up and be like i'm gonna try
harvesting this power
i don't think she cared and i think to
answer the question that's true
she might have looked around west view
and just saw how sad these people were i
think in that moment she was just
thinking about her and her grief
she was she was just she was being
selfish in the right ways because after
that when she
went yeah i was like do it girl i said
take it over
assimilate do everything i don't care
i'm heartbroken for you
oh that scene i was like do it we have
time for one more
question that we're going to take this
question kind of off topic but
do the avengers get paid so how did how
did they get
how did rwanda envision get that
property
they according to which i don't know i
don't know
in the mcu but in the comic books they
get a stipend because there's a comic
book
where when wanda like kind of goes off
again
she makes uh she makes iron man look bad
and drunk in front of everyone so
everyone's like
oh we don't want anything to do with him
so they lose their money
and he can't give money to the avengers
anymore
and that's how she like did it in like a
weird like stockbroker crashing way of
just being like
i'm just gonna mess with his appearance
to make him lose money
so they are getting money through a
stipend in the comic books and some of
the comic books i don't know about the
mcu i sure i'm sure they
they better get like a fortune they're
putting their lives on the line
um yeah the um it's
i mean tony stark has always been
independently wealthy and it seemed like
he just used his own
money to fund the avengers compound um
and that all their expenses were just
kind of covered room and board
um and what else do they really need but
like for sure
hawkeye was working for shield uh before
the
avengers came together and he was able
to afford like a farmhouse
uh he was probably not that high up on
our payroll
but i assume they're making six figures
at least to kind of cover them you think
they get mad at each other's different
income
like hawkeye looks at captain america
and is just like how much you make
he's like i don't want to talk about it
he's like i don't want to talk about it
and you know
you know captain america was like we
don't need to talk about this we
shouldn't be asking each other's
you know rates in person like this you
should really just like we shouldn't
talk about it hr
for the avengers is like don't talk
about it don't talk about it we did an
episode of big question talking about
how much the avengers get paid and who
is the poorest avenger and i think we
concluded that uh
over his lifetime bruce banner has been
the poorest because he's been like
homeless for most of his life
he's gonna walk around mexico okay
that's
choosing he chose most of his like path
i would technically say that the poorest
one is probably thor because he's like
what do i need your money for and it
goes
away so he's like he's he's like what's
money
yeah what's money we abolished capital
backed four thousand years or ago yeah
he's like he laughs like he pulls out
the communist manifesto and he
gives you a little marxist lecture and
then you're like huh that actually could
work
captain america says i'm leaving this
and then that's where we get black adam
um and he comes from dc into he goes
from dc into marvel
uh yeah i was i assume that or maybe
just property value in west view new
jersey is real cheap
it definitely is you saw that place i'm
not trying to be rude but you saw the
location
and location means a lot and that looked
like it was pretty cheap
my hometown looks just like that you
guys i i kid you not
and it's cheap there my rent was 600 for
a one bedroom apartment
you can't get that in l that doesn't
even exist in la you could probably get
a toilet
that's a box on skid row oh absolutely
600
i'm i was living it and i didn't even
know at that time
this is now a podcast where i talk about
commercial real
real estate well we want to thank you
guys so much
it's been so great to hear your
questions there's a lot more that we're
going to be talking about this final
uh upcoming final episode of one
division uh in episode
eight on the channel we got a new title
for spider-man uh no way home
uh falcon winter soldiers coming up uh
it's such an exciting time jessica i
wanna thank you it's been so great
talking about episode eight with you i
can't wait to talk about the finale with
you it's gonna be the finale and then no
one will hear of me again i go back into
the shadows
until underneath my bed
i'm gonna go under my bed too just to
sleep uh because
my ingredients sleeping oh yes it's too
hard because i'm like
thinking like oh wait no the swanovision
theory could be the case like i gotta go
to a place that
is it because you don't have the helix
mattress um
oh i have the alex matches okay cool
cool just making sure just uh going back
to brands
you can pop a pill and pop
you said it you said it you said it that
was your ad
i didn't say that you're right uh well
thank you
so much be sure to follow jessica at
lulu underscore clements follow me at
eavos follow new rockstars be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars on youtube
hit that notification bell
and uh check out one of our many great
merch options at newarkstoresmirch.com
uh and we love all of you and we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
you